so we're happy to have mika continue her
uh tutorial from yesterday so this is
going to be going into journal some
games and general synthetic interactions
and
collaborative interactions
yeah thanks again okay thank you for
being here can i just ask um is there
anybody in the room today who
didn't manage to catch any part of the
previous day's tutorial that i gave
it's okay if you can confess okay
that's uh that's it and i just wanted to
see how much of a
overview i have to give so since
everybody was here we can actually uh
dive right in but
i let me just set the stage anyway to
sort of remember what we were talking
about
because uh
yesterday we dedicated most of almost
all of the time actually to thinking
about interactions with an adversary
and that meant that we talked about
online learning min max optimization um
what kind of connections between them
and a little bit about um
what happens like what is so brilliant
brittle about adversarial interactions
and how we can sort of think more about
more socially realistic uh ways of
thinking about adversaries and then we
saw how classical
things you've learned from theory of
machine learning still stays very
relevant today to the needs of beyond
worst case analysis and learning to
understanding games
and at the end i also talked a little
bit about computational aspects but sort
of in the interest of time i didn't go
into the details of it
so what i tried to do today is to
actually
have the remainder of tutorial be
essentially independent of that
computational aspect
so
uh
just to be fair to you because i didn't
go through it so don't worry we are not
going to go over it again
but you're also not going to really need
to talk about
computational aspects of
the first part as much anymore
so what we're going to do today is
think much more about general thumb as
vessels said rather than thinking about
uh sort of adversarial interaction
thinking about more general uh
incentives and strategic uh structure
and
then we're going to see something very
specific which is more about
collaborative interactions and then i'll
highlight once we get to the end as to
some of the
connections that might have not been as
obvious
uh i'll just uh repeat them so that we
kind of can bring them back in our minds
okay
if you have any questions at any point
feel free to stop me i really enjoyed
that yesterday we were having a
conversation essentially that was
uh very enjoyable for me but i think it
also helped a lot of other people in the
room actually follow along better
cool so let's start
kind of in terms of the structure of
this section of the tutorial which is
going to be essentially this full hour
and maybe a little bit of the next hour
we're going to talk about general sum
games and then we're going to talk about
some of the solution concepts in these
general sum games
how you'd compute them
how you will learn about them and also
thinking about
non-myopic behavior which is something
we haven't yet talked about at all but
we'll get there
okay so
let's start with general sum games and
if you recall from yesterday we talked
about zero sum games and we saw that
zero sum games
were sort of the point of them were to
capture our interactions with an
adversary so whenever we were gaining
they were losing and vice versa
general some games relax at the
assumption that my gain is your loss or
your gain is my loss by saying that
there are these more general aspects of
how your utilities translate to mine
and you could think about them as more
general strategic manipulations that are
not necessarily
malicious but there are just type of
interactions that somebody is just
trying to optimize uh stuff in their own
life and it still affects us
so examples of this we talked about a
very little bit at the very beginning of
yesterday's session
was in ride sharing apps where drivers
or even riders try to manipulate um
whether or not they're available for a
ride whether or not they're going to
accept the ride at this moment
in the hope that immediately
you know soon after like in the next 15
minutes in the next half an hour the
next day they're gonna get better rates
um another example we very briefly again
talked about that's good to bring back
in your mind is
um admissions uh hiring
lendings a lot of other search type
problems
where we're essentially looking at some
available representation of a person
their cv their
any other information we have about them
and we're making decisions based on that
but the person has ability to change the
cv either changing the representation of
it or even maybe getting some
qualification doing some certificate
certificate courses
and
again they're not being malicious
they're not trying to mess up my
learning algorithm
all they're trying to do is to actually
get better deal out of the learning
algorithm and that's why this is more
generally strategic rather than zero
okay so
we're going to look at the same uh
set up
the only difference is now that we are
not making any assumption about zero sum
which means that we're going to be
talking about general utilities u1 and
u2
as before if i use the capital of u1 and
u2 it just means that i'm
accounting for expectations
and because we don't have the zero sum
assumption
we also don't have the min max theorem
the min max theorem if you remember
one way to say it was that
it doesn't matter if you go first or
last it's all the same
and you're going to lose this very nice
property
and
what that means is that
now it actually does matter who's going
to go first and
an example of this is
just remember that we're again going to
work with these make strategies where
each player is going to pick
a strategy that is a distribution over
actions
and let's look at such an
a matrix it's no longer zero sum
so if you were to be player one and uh i
was interested in your nash equilibrium
in a national degree of this game
what now a nash equilibria would look
like would say that
well
nash equilibria means that
neither of the players can unilaterally
improve their payoff by just changing
their own strategy
and the interesting thing here is that
this is actually quite simple to compute
for this game because player one
has a dominant strategy what that means
is that for every
cell if no matter what player two has
played player one would rather play up
because it's getting more utility by
playing up
regardless of what player two has done
so what this is saying is that well
player one in any nash equilibria should
be playing up
now what does the second player do the
second the player number two would do
well player number two knows that player
number one has committed to this
essentially because in any national
equilibria you have to be here
so player number two says that okay but
i'm going to gain more utility by
actually going left
so
this
ul is going to be the only the the nash
equilibrium which happens to also be
pure in this game
note that in this setting player one is
getting plus one utility
so nash equilibria you can think about
it as some kind of a simultaneous player
right we both come we both go with p and
q and this is the outcome we are going
to get
now
let's consider a setting where player
one could
actually verifiably commit to their
strategy what that looks like is that
they actually pick a strategy
and uh
they somehow either shout it out there's
somebody who's holding them responsible
after they have shouted out their
strategy there's no way that they're
going to change it maybe there's a
contract there's no way to back out
so now if player one could commit in a
verifiable way
now what can happen is that let's say
player one decided for whatever reason
to commit to playing down
what would player two do
player two is going to say well player
one has already committed to being here
what i am going to do
is to see what i'm going to gain um
and i'm going to i should have changed
it slightly so that would have been a
little bit higher so i'm going to
actually play a right
because
let's assume this was one plus a little
bit
so i'm going to play right
and what happens here is that
this is the outcome i'm going to see
and player one is actually getting more
utility
so player one benefited from the ability
to commit
this is what it means to go first in a
and commit in a verifiable way
in fact player one could have committed
to a slightly different strategy a
random a mixed strategy
by saying that i'm gonna go up
almost half the time
and i'm going to go down the other half
the time
and this is still good enough for the
player to be encouraged to take column
number r
and what happens is that player number
one is going to be able to get 2.5
utility which is the best player number
one can do if it were to commit to a
mixed strategy
so what is this saying
this thing
this is saying that there is a different
solution concept which is not nash it's
not min-max it's not max-min
that is what you should be paying
attention to and this is called the
stackelberg solution concept
with stackelberg
optimal solution and sometimes i also
refer to it as zuckerberg equilibrium
is
is that player one is going to take the
position of a leader
and player two is going to take the
position of a follower leader and
followers are different
the leader has to commit to a mixed
strategy p
and then the follower will best respond
to this strategy that was announced
what is this best response it's just the
best action it's going to take given
that p has been committed to
now it's a cycleberg
optimal solution if the leader commits
to the best mixed strategy
accounting for the fact that the
follower is going to respond
is going to be shown this way
uh oh this should be p
so this is called a mixed zuckerberg
equilibrium
if i don't call it mix just assume it's
mixed by default
so what we showed in the previous slide
is that there are some gains that
stackelberg equilibria for the first
player
has better payoff than any nash
equilibrium
in fact
what we can show is something very
general
and uh
this is also due to bonstangela and
zemir uh from previous slide
um which is that in any general sun game
the stackelberg equilibrium's payoff to
the first player is at least weakly
better than any nash equilibrium
that's a question yeah
there's
actually the way that people usually
imagine it is that yeah maybe there's a
contract or the environment itself is
allowing for this somebody's enforcing
this
or the environment by itself is
enforcing yeah either a third party or
just the channel that's there is
enforcing it so let's say that what i do
is i actually play
my chips and then i
come back and then it gets realized
um
and you're even thinking about a
cryptographic way to enforce it
that uh
this idea that they actually have to
follow up
is not so clear
yeah
so i can give you two examples of this
where this is being used in practice i
have i have slides about this but maybe
it's also a good place to say this so
one place that this is used especially
in the mixed uh
stackelberg
concept
is for physical security not for digital
security and the idea is that for
physical security
sort of your commitment uh is something
like almost like this this
petrolling schedule that you have
and then uh
criminals or whatever people who are
trying to abuse
and get around the security features
that you have installed are the ones who
sort of know this commitment because
they've seen it
and then they're trying to get around it
um there's another example which is for
slightly different notion of stackelberg
equilibrium i'll give that in a minute
um yeah
someone will say that
i don't want to say that it is easier
but now it's like simulated
to
find what they want
so
let's see if that's a fair
characterization or not
you're right that i can think about this
function as just a function of p
if i knew what the best response was
but to be fair even in the min max you
were doing the same thing
this is a generalization of mind maps so
in fact
if this was a zero sum game the stack
over equilibrium payoff is the same as
maximum and max and nash equilibrium
fail
so
this is not
actually getting around the fact that
it's not making the problem just a
simple maximization of the concave
function
you're right that it's the structure
itself
and we're going to see a little bit more
about that structure so
i believe that uh
please correct me if i'm wrong like if i
compute a nash that is a solution to
this type of verb it's not the optimal
solution sure but it is right yeah
so why is it a solution so nash requires
stability on both sides right so nash
requires that the player the
the follower best response and the
leader also best responsive follower
stack over the advantage is that it's
actually relaxing the fact that the
meter has to be best response
that's why exactly this
result holds because it's a relaxation
of notch
um and you're gonna see that kind of
like i think uh
uh
you were asking about computation we're
going to actually see this the fact that
now you're not really looking for a
fixed point anymore it's going to help
us in terms of computation but it's
still a function of
it's still not a complete function
that's easy to
just maximize
okay
so this is just
this is about
mixed strategy stockholder
optimal psychological equilibrium
now there's also a notion of pure
strategy
solution concepts
for zappover and it's exactly the same
as before the only thing here is that
now the leader has to come into a pure
strategy
and it has to come into the best pure
strategy knowing that your the followers
want the best response so enforcing
these actions are easier because there's
nothing on non-deterministic is
happening in the environment um
and one thing about this is that
because this is about pureness now it's
unfair to compare the
pure stackelberg optimal solution to a
mixed matter equilibrium in fact um
if i were to commit it to a
uh to compare to pure nash it would have
been fine but pure nash is not
guaranteed to exist
so you will lose the nice
characterization of this
but let me say that in most applications
when we actually talk about kerosene
equilibrium
um
our environment is really really
structured
in the sense that
in fact
you have sort of like convectivity on
concavity and concavity in the right
ways
almost in an artificially right way
just so that you don't lose too much by
talking about pure stack over
this is not going to be the focus of my
talk i'll give some examples about it
but essentially i'm going to treat it
the same as i would a mx strategy
equilibrium because
whenever we work with it it happens to
have a lot of nice structures that we
want anyway
okay so
kind of like what you would think about
such a result about stackelberg
equilibrium what it's telling you is
that commitment is actually good for you
in the sense that if you can go first
and commit it's much better to check to
take that option
rather than rely on something that's
like a general nash equilibrium
in terms of applications i'm going to
give you two applications so this is the
first one i was talking about the notion
of physical security
the idea is that in security games
sophisticated attackers target the
weakest point of a system
and so what you want to do is that
you're going to protect targets so that
the targets that are higher value to you
are not being attacked
of course what value you assign to a
target is different than a value that an
adversary might assign and that's why
this is not necessarily a zero-sum game
here the leader or the defender has a
set of resources access
and it can choose how to assign
resources to different targets and
usually like you actually want this to
be random because you want it to be um
unpredictable a little bit so you will
decide that such and such police force
is going to be actually looking at such
and such street or such and such
neighborhood with some
random schedule of events the attacker
here its strategy said is a set of
targets
and u1 and u2 are essential utilities
that depend only on whether the
resources that you had in x were
assigned to
protecting the target why that was
attacked if it wasn't protected and it
was an attack you're not going to get
any utility from it
so this is an example of security games
it's actually something that the the
specific
model of security games that i mentioned
to has been used a lot in practice for
um for stopping actually poaching
activities for checking tickets on you
know on trains and buses that
in the la area
that you don't actually have to card in
you sit in the train and you have you
know your ticket somebody has to come
and check it that's been used by coast
guard by a lot of different security
agencies
the other example is the example of
strategic classification
strategic classification
uh here the decisions uh are
this this is like thinking about again
admissions lending
hiring the idea is that the decisions
are based on some observable attributes
and people can actually change those
attributes to some degree
the learner here is the leader who's
trying to come up with a classifier
such that
when a distribution of followers respond
to it
is still a good classifier now what does
responding look like each follower has
some initial representation
and they may have to pay a cost to
change this a little bit maybe they're
just changing their presentation of
their cv maybe they're taking some
certificate courses
and then what u1 and u2 are capturing is
either the accuracy of this hypothesis
on the new representation versus the old
representation
maybe it's how much you encourage people
to actually take certificate courses
that are good for them rather than just
manipulating their cvs
these are settings that we typically
think about pure strategy but as i said
it's even the pure strategy setting is
highly structured in these settings
in particular here uh pure strategy
itself is like a parameterized
classifier and if you are working with
parameterized like linear classifiers
you're already putting a lot of
structure on your domain
so these are two
examples of application domains
and
next i'm going to talk about how you
would now compute these equilibriums
because there were already some
questions about that
[Music]
yeah so
there are a lot of stories uh
there was a
there was an insurance company that was
tracking i think maybe your fitbit or
like the number of steps that people
were taking
um to set insurance rates so then there
were all these like hamster wheels for
your fitbit
that were sort of counting it up and it
was a very low cost manipulation that's
one example of this um but these uh
have been used in different places uh
there are some
entertaining stories about them so
that's that's an example of this by the
uh maybe a more lighthearted story of
that but they're definitely darker on
this one
or something
i don't know if they were useless
i think they they definitely changed
their approaches i don't know if they
actually use this type of robustness yet
um
yeah i actually
think whether or not people have
actually used this uh
after they have figured out that they
messed something up or not i don't have
a good example right now
um but this has been used a lot to
actually
identify uh
situations where people are doing these
types of manipulations
or where these types of manipulations
are in particular bad for some
um equity or furnace uh aspects as well
those are definitely i would say there
are still more scientific research
rather than saying that some company
changed or approaches using specifically
strategic classification if i don't know
of it but they've definitely been used
to analyze them
so
just one thing about the
how sequential you're
doing this this is still
like
at the same time you go into something
knowing that i went first no no so i
have to go first and shout it and then
yeah or or the history is enforcing it
i'll talk a little bit about this but uh
you have
so the best response is coming after
your strategy has announced right only
once
you can right now think about that this
is being played only once we're gonna
come back and change that a little bit
but then we talk about zachelberg it's
just a two-round game it's not an
intimately mini roundup game
and the idea is that if you know
everything about you one on youtube you
can just do this computation and this is
telling you what's the best policy to
commit to and then you should never
touch that policy you just commit to it
and that's it you're done that's the
best you could do
but then um if you didn't know then
there are questions about
oh what am i going to do
uh it seems like i need to maybe tune my
strategy and is that going to mess up
with all of this executive structure
we'll talk about that sort of at the end
of the section okay
other questions yeah so just be sure
the way that i see it is the following i
aim
to commit to publicly to strategy so i'm
thinking
first given that
what is the best response of the other
player
when i would commit and they would
choose the best one that
would give me the best for me yeah
yeah exactly you sort of pre-compute in
your head this best response function
so
then you sort of choose the best action
for yourself
accounting for the best response
okay so sorry i needed some changes to a
presenter
so that i can move between this side
more easily
okay so next we're going to talk about
how would compute stackelberg
equilibrium
and
an important aspect of this is to
actually look at that utility function
the if you wanted to just parameterize
it just by your actions accounting for
best response what does this look like
well we need to compute this right this
is the function that i only care about
essentially if i knew this best response
like the best response is computed this
way but that's i'm going to plug it in
and i'm going to look at that u1
so you could think about it this way but
let me tell you that in most cases this
is not an advantage this is not actually
a simplification because if you look at
this u1 of p as a function of just p
you're going to end up with non-convex
non-concave non-lipschitz functions that
are
so messy that you didn't actually gain
anything there are very rare situations
and i would say that
partially like artificially curated
sometimes to make them be almost licious
and almost complex or concave and there
are some examples of this
if you want to look at where in
strategic classification what kind of
classifiers in real life actually have
those properties this paper has a really
nice list of them
so generally these functions are not
very well behaved
but
what you can see is that even if they
might not be well behaved over their
full domain they still appear to have
piecewise nice properties and we can see
them
okay so let's take a look at this again
so i want to compute the mixed
tackleberg uh optimal solution
and i'm in any finite game
so
this is exactly what i need to compute
and there is this very general approach
that says that
actually this is like computing multiple
linear programs this is called the
multiple lp approach
and the idea is that
maybe this is complex if i just look at
this function
but this best response function is going
to take only y different values those
are the columns in my game actions of
the adversary actions of the follower
so let's fix each action and let's just
look at my mix strategies that would
have been consistent with that best
response
this set of this is the set of
strategies that are consistent with the
best response
now what do i see
that's it happens to be a polytop
it's a polytope because it's defined
by these
half spaces separating when my strategy
sorry the follower strategy y
is better than any other y prime
and remember that these capital letters
are always linear functions they're just
telling you
expectation of something
so you have two linear functions you're
thresholding them and you're taking an
intersection of them
which means that
i if i just look at what kind of
strategies would lead to a follower
taking a specific type of action
then i am looking at um
at the polytops
so once i compute the polytopes then all
i need to do
is to find the best solution in every
palatal and take the best out of all of
them
right
it happens to be that not only these
polytropes are linear but the best thing
that i'm trying to optimize this u1 of
pmy that is also a linear function again
it's a capital letter meaning
expectation
so that i can optimize easily with a
linear program
so what this is saying is that you just
run a linear program
per
column of the game
and then take the best one
and this is going to be your
optimal stackelberg equilibrium
how much time does it take well it's
going to be polynomial on the sides of
the game
because i have to run an lp for each one
and
the lp is in the dimension of my row
space
any questions about this
the our mag had
okay so that's a good question um
so
i simplified this by talking about the
player number two only playing pure
strategies and in general it's uh this
is uh
it's okay to make this assumption
because
uh you you assume that um
players who always can for any
non-deterministic strategy there's a
different strategy that's getting just
as much so there's no reason to look
beyond
but if they so because of that it
doesn't actually affect it
the only thing that it affects is that
it's actually changing the meaning of
stuff over
equilibrium and typically the ops like
people like you might have a lot of uh
zuckerberg uh
you might have the best response is a
set not necessarily a single
exactly it's like it could be a set of
columns rather than a single column
and you usually think about high
breaking and the worst or in the best
case for the leader and once you make
whatever assumption you're making you
can adjust all of this
let me tell you that it doesn't really
matter
essentially what's happening is that
you have these different regions like v1
p2 p3
what happens is that
let's say that this is something that
looks like this strategy uh that would
have been optimal for one type breaking
as long as i move it a little bit in
it's approximately optimal
and it's
out of the
um usually
so it's essentially you could you could
really ignore these types for now
in fact for the duration of this
tutorial but they're they're interesting
i should take a look at it especially
when you want to think more about robots
algorithms so they come up again
other questions
oh
maybe
i'm wrong that i thought that these
political might have exponentially
points
corners so that the linear program may
not
be feasible
well you can talk about the separation
oracle because it's a polytope with y
number of hypotheses
half spaces
then you don't have to think about the
corners you can just think about the
separation
other questions
we have right now assumption about the
u1 if it is 1k or not
okay remember whenever we have uh
capital letters here they mean
expectation so we actually have
linearity for that okay
okay
yeah so that's the advantage of talking
about mixed strategies
and uh
and finite games i don't need to make
any additional assumptions finite games
by itself is a strong enough assumption
to do with this okay
okay
so
so this is also a minute to take a pause
and
uh
realize and notice this that
this is much easier than that that
simple relaxation on one side the fact
that i don't have to find a fixed point
is making this essentially polynomial in
the size of the game whereas we know in
general um and uh jonas on nash
equilibrium is hard to copy
so not only this gives you a better
utility to the leader
but also it actually allows the leader
to compute it more effectively
okay what is an example of this multiple
lp approach i want how to maybe
understand a little bit better i'm going
to give an example from
the security games um just so that you
also maybe gain some appreciation of
what security games and
practice on what to look like
so this is a part of green security game
these are
security games that are used to stop
poaching or to limit it
and you can think about it that there
are two types of potential targets
you're trying to
um
to protect you have elephants and
gorillas they're both close to
extinction so you want to protect them
and you have maybe sort of one resource
that could be sent to one or the other
now these two targets are slightly
different in terms of how you value them
and how an
a follower values them
11 elephants have ivory tusks so they're
very expensive
attackers would love to get their hands
on them
um on the other hand gorillas are closer
to extinction so you really don't want
them to be attacked so this is why it's
not necessarily a general sange
you also have two resources
one it's a little bit of a
um
oversimplification you can decide which
of these two areas you're going to send
your resource
it turns out that what you would do in a
si in an optimal zuckerberg is to use
almost one third on the gorillas and
almost two thirds on the elephants
you do care about worlds more and the
attackers care about them less so you
can get away with actually a little bit
less protection than half and half and
that's why one third two thirds is
optimal
now what does it look like in terms of
the optimization
this is the face of the optimization i
should have drawn it on a line
but 2d simplex is a little bit easier to
see so any point here is a probability
of how much you're protecting elephants
on how much you're protecting the
guerrillas
and it's divided to two parts
how does these the two parts are defined
is that constraints on the
followers utilities these are the lines
this line says that i prefer to attack
the elephants over attacking gorillas
and they are written by the difference
and by
the comparison of the expected utility
of the second player
now once you are written a region
you're looking at the objective which is
the leader's objective
again it's a linear function it's the
expectation
and now it's ignoring player number two
it's just player number one
so that's what linear program would look
like we take each of these regions those
are your pfi's and for each of them it
will optimize this linear function
any questions about this
about the application how do you decide
google first
good uh the in all of these back over
games the idea is that the person can
set up policy is the person who's going
first so that's why uh protection
policies admission policies those are
those are usually long term and they're
sort of verifiably somebody speaking to
them because they have put a lot of
money or resources into making that
happen
that's and that's why
there is a difference in power so
usually these rules are not inversible
unless you actually don't have a
hierarchy of power which then messes
things up
so good point i'll talk a little bit
sort of towards the end sort of
algorithmic perspective on who is
committing and who's not committing is
itself an interesting way of doing this
okay so here really one thing we don't
want to forget is that
we want to think we want to think about
these general sum games and especially
uh stack over exhibition and commitment
in them
because they're both easier and better
so whenever we can commit we should
really use that
okay we talked about computing the
cyclebird equilibria
but
the computation needed us to know the
game matrix
the question is how much information we
actually need to know
and in realistic situations do we have
that information or not
okay
so in the realistic situations what is a
typically that we do know and what is it
that we don't know
well for this specific scenario of
general some games and let's think about
security
i may know how much me as the leader
values the different targets i might
know how close girls are to extinction i
might know how close elephants are to
extinction
that's the my half of the matrix that
you want
the thing that's harder to know is what
is u2
because even in the security games even
though i even know about the ivory task
being valuable it also really depends on
what resources are available to the
adversary and to the attackers and many
other things like where they sleeping at
night
uh what are
how close they are to any of these
targets
so that is you too and i do not know
youtube um
sometimes you can do market research for
certain things to figure this out but
usually it's quite sensitive
but the thing that we are hopefully able
to observe actually that's at least as a
simplifying assumption is that even if
you don't know u2 you can always observe
what people have done you can see what
they've done in the past what targets
they've attacked what targets they're
going to attack right now
so that's the actual action of the
follower
now
what you're going to really be thinking
about here is if i'm trying to think
about learning especially work optimal
strategy
what i'm trying to do is to compute this
function
without actually knowing the py
because
u1 i know
i just don't know the optimization
region because the optimization region
was the thing that really required me
knowing what u2 is that's the politics
so how can i do this
how can i optimize
a linear function
over an unknown uh
that's the gist of the problem here
really if you could do it
then you could do the multiple lp
approach that i was recommending and put
it all together
any questions about this
so i wrote this in this very specific
form of polytopes there would have been
many different ways of solving this
because the answer essentially going to
come out of this representation
so
how do ellipsoid that's
so it looks like technically needs a
separation oracle
[Music]
so
so that's that's a good question so if i
give you a separate if i give you
an oracle which is just about br can you
get separation oracle that's certainly
something you could do in fact there's
more generally
this thing is called a membership query
let's say that
for every
i have a politics
i don't know a separation i cannot for
any point i cannot separate it
but if you put something in it i can
tell you whether it's in or out if you
put something out i will tell you that
it's out
so
there are definitely ways to reconstruct
separation from membership but you can
even do it more directly
here i'm actually going to cite uh
uh okay
i'm going to actually give you an
example of a
very nice work that actually covers all
of the questions that you have how can i
go from one form of oracle to another
how can i optimize with a lower form of
oracle
uh i'll do that in the next slide but
before i do that i just wanted to tell
you what this looks like because i
somewhat jumped a little bit to
membership queries
so
this br
how am i going to use it
essentially i'm starting with not
knowing anything and
br is going to tell me that this is
going to be in the elephant region and
at least this is going to tell me a
little bit about the area and what i
have to do is to decide how i'm going to
like search the rest of this
you could think that it's almost like a
binary search but on a larger
dimensional space that's a little bit
more complicated than that in fact you
want one one algorithm that can use this
as like simulated annealing there are a
bunch of other algorithms it's
independent and we're not going to talk
about it in the tutorial
but you can read about these
the optimization from membership oracles
with membership queries
is a well studied really interesting
branch of optimization
uh
we've known even before kalaemampala
we have known algorithms for this
problem but
the bound i gave you is from the 2018
paper
so we could do this we could do this
quite effectively actually
so now that we know how to solve an lp
we can put it back in the wrapper that i
was suggesting to you
and put it in the
in the linear program formulation
and
just solve these problems that's going
to give you for any finite game
an approach for
learning this zuckerberg equilibrium
now the number of queries is going to
depend polynomially on the number of the
rows and number of the columns
there are other ways to do this for
certain games you can do much better
i'm not going to go into the details of
them for security games in particular
you can do much better
for certain other games you don't need
to depend on the size of the game but
you can depend on certain structures in
the game
um there are also other approaches that
can be used here yeah i always have to
think of how this stuff gets implemented
yeah so what um
[Music]
okay
it's a good question because it's an
over simplification in its simplest form
so what i'm technically suggesting to
you is to sacrifice the five borders
that you have left
because what am i saying i'm saying
you're going to start knowing nothing
um
you're going to start knowing nothing
knowing nothing and then you're going to
actually add random to some point here
this is the point
and then
you might see that
actually this point is quite optimal and
maybe you even know and suspected this
points of optimal and then you see an
elephant getting attacked
and then the next time you're like okay
i'm gonna move this and the next time
your gorilla is getting attacked and
technically if you do this before you
can figure out a good strategy your
whole population of elephants and
gorillas are dead
so this is not this is not the way you
should put this in practice
nevertheless this is actually used to to
inform practical decisions
um
it's not directly the multiple lp
approach i gave you is more of a
scientific exercise
but these learnings uh especially like
slightly like safer ways of learning
is what you would do um
especially in sort of low value
like when to check tickets
i think about photographically if i
think about there's all these situations
and i think of this as data rather than
right
i'm going to tackle not but maybe more
about the value of data and depending on
that would they take an action
then you could have some kind of uh
maybe multi-party computation or you
could have
seen it but with that you know what i'm
saying so there might be waste i'm not
sure if i caught that thing so
you want to know what would have
happened yeah
it would have done that
um
um
[Music]
who are the parties are you asking the
adversary to do some compensation for
you is that how i should think about
that and uh even though we split it
there's some great difference
would you want like accessories
um
i'm not sure if i understand the role of
crypto here
um
you're not going to make an action
because then uh the
monkeys or whatever they are the
gorillas are gonna
get attacked if i understood it
so you have to think of other ways to
realize i think you're saying that
nonetheless people have ways to realize
it and then they're getting so so the
way i would fix this i still have to
think i'm still not sure how i would
think about rule of
crypto
because this is
another way to think about this is that
this is about lack of information right
so what i'm saying is
i'm saying that instead of doing it
instead of taking actions and then
seeing responses you could sort of do a
simulation of what would it be
that's definitely what you're trying
what the results would have been without
actually doing the action that's
definitely true so this is definitely an
exercise so this
like at a high level falls on there you
are you've taken listen if you haven't
taken any actions then you are starting
from no information so then you don't
have much but you have some observations
usually and that observation has brought
it down to some set of uncertainty
regions and then you're trying to
understand those uncertainty regions a
little bit better and that's you could
sort of hallucinate the utility for the
adversary and then best respond to that
utility um i'm going to talk a little
bit about online decisions which
actually do something like that they are
not but when you are happy you have to
make these kind of fast decisions
in other words
you know without check without taking
action
but they do release some information
which is what the oracle query would
have been
what would they ask oracle would have
been
had you
were saying but yeah i mean
let me put what you said in a different
way um i could have designed a game uh
and i could have released it and asked a
bunch of uh
um
[Music]
i'm not a stereotype teenager sorry uh
i'm gonna ask a bunch of teenagers to
play this game for me and then i'm gonna
look at the simulation that is produced
by a bunch of people playing some kind
of strategic game especially if it was a
pretty complex game
as an estimation of what my best
response is
that's true i can always
have these other sources of messages
that you're really going to have in the
game
because
that's okay actually
uh what i don't know is whether or not
people are actually like what is the
utility of the people or how rational
people are so i can do these experiments
to get an estimation of the stress
response
to have a warm start for my algorithm
and then come up with a very like small
set of piece uncertainty sets and then
try this
because in order to do crypto i need to
know what the response would have been
exactly so i get i need to see the best
response or an estimate of it now i can
come up with different tricks to getting
that estimate
uh
but at the end of the day it's about
information that i need to see from
whatever it means
i saw a bunch of hands i don't know the
orders you will do one wrong next
what goes first
comments
i also want to inject uh something not
crypto but
okay kind of analysis
so why not
uh it's not competitive analysis it's a
regret but you can actually nicely go
between no he can go between regret
competitiveness
nine minutes uh
how about are there questions no i
wanted just to answer that so maybe we
can take that offline
do you have a question oh yeah just um
so we're assuming here that youtube is
fixed right
good i'm not going to relax is that the
question
so you guys are all ahead uh
let's go back to where we were
ah it's just the next slide okay so um
okay so i had uh i had made a
simplifying assumption in some sense
it's not necessarily simplifying but i
assume that there is one type of
follower or and even if i don't know it
is somewhat fixed
um and i had assumed that i'm spending
all of this time uh coming up with a
solution and then implementing that
solution at the end
but you could have thought about this
problem as one that is an online way of
decision making you'll have some system
you're making some decisions and then
you're going to tweet these decisions
and you can even think about
having potentially different types of
followers being presented to you
that are they coming
from some distribution or they're coming
adversarially from some sense
so
in a repeated game formulation i could
actually write this as something that we
now call stackelberg regret
and spikelberg regret is very similar to
the other notion of regret we talked
about in the sense that i am going to
measure the leader's utility
per round and average it out
but the thing i'm computing competing
against
is going to be the cycle of optimal
strategy why is this a stack of work
optimal strategy um
first note that this t i put here is
exactly for what was the suggestion
which was if i i'm dealing with a
different follower or what would that
happen
if i fix this follower this is the
definition of a stackelberg optimal
strategy
now if i don't fix it it's essentially
the zuckerberg optimal strategy for the
sequence that i have observed
so this is what we call a stackelberg
regret
and if you have an algorithm that has
low speckled regret what it now means is
that maybe you were never close really
to what you have uh
to to this strategy itself but the
utility that you gathered around when at
every time the follower somewhat
myopically responded to you best
responded to you
would have not been very far from the
stack over equilibrium
that's how you would interpret this
stackelberg regret
and the idea is that um
actually the type of offline algorithms
i told you the search algorithms that
they spend a lot of time with membership
query or whatnot and then they learn
something they could all be turned into
online algorithms that spend that time
in one way or another in an online
fashion and either towards the end they
are
comfortable enough to commit to
something or they continue sort of
exploring
and never necessarily committing
so
there are these algorithms that are
designed for stackelberg regret many of
them are actually inspired by the type
of algorithm i already gave you which
spends some time searching and then
comments
so is peace or that
it's decided in hindsight so i stopped
the sequence i looked back and i did
finance
okay so now we have two notions of
regrets that you've been talking about
the stackover which i just introduced
and then what we talked about yesterday
i'm gonna refer to that external record
that's another way
just another terminology for the same
idea
and they're slightly different from each
other so
if i were to think about external
regrets
external regret forget about cyberburn
for a second what it was saying was that
you look back in hindsight you see the
observations the actions that were taken
and you try to optimize for those
actions
that is
this
type of uh maximization
in the sense that the observations
were not at all a response to the
optimal thing i'm doing it's not about
the policy it's the actual observations
on my algorithm for whatever reason the
adversary had produced for it
well zuckerberg regrets
the benchmark
has in it
this type of the best response built
into it
so they're different from each other
and they're different from each other
in the sense that in the worst case
they're incompatible
what does that mean it means that
they're really optimizing for two
different notions
if i get a stackover norwegian
zuckerberg algorithm and no stack will
be quick algorithm
it's going to have regret external
regret on some sequences
and vice versa if i get an algorithm
that's guaranteed to be no external
regret
it's going to have stack over regret and
something else
why is this the case
it's essentially at the heart of it
partly
is that same difference i was telling
you about
um
mid max maximum sacco bird nash all of
that
in some way you're looking at utility in
this hindsight on historical
observations versus utility on best
responses
in fact the advantage of cycle verb
optimal strategy
was as as courses asked was that it was
the leader was not best responded that's
that relaxation was the thing that was
allowing you to do better than
other solution concepts
and the the cycle sorry the external
regret is essentially telling you that
you should be long-term disrespondent
otherwise you will have some of that and
that's why
in some sense stackelberg's solution
must leave on the table at least as it
appears for the historical
observations something
so that it appears like not stable it's
not historically it's not taking the
full benefit of historical uh
full benefit of utility on historical
observations
also
on the other hand external regret is not
at all accounting for what this
hypothetical of what would have happened
if i did this or did that it's just
talking about the history rather than
the type of history that would have been
produced as part of your policy
and that's why this work
okay
i'm gonna start
from here
and i know that break is coming soon but
i already see some questions so how
about we pause now i'll take some
questions
and then we'll continue in 15 minutes
does that sound good
thank you so are there any class of uh
games in english
for the you can
we don't have a characterization but one
class is zero-sum games but i'm cheating
because that's just what you see
um i'm not even sure if convex concave
has a property
i don't know
phrase must appear
should appear not necessary it's not in
every game but in some game it must that
must happen in some way
and just follow
the question
do we
have any information about also for any
convex printing
no i i don't know so like i haven't
thought about this question before
do you ask me to give it a class i'll
cheat by saying sometimes but the more
reasonable answer i don't have right now
other questions
could you say something about
no special regret algorithms what they
do
yes am i going to talk about them
um
not really okay
so
good
so let's go after the example i was
giving you with you spent some time
doing a subtle test response
now one example of this is
you could hallucinate a type of
adversary
or you might not even come into a
certain type of adversary but like just
kind of try to cover your bases for a
bunch of different types of adversaries
so the fact that you are never again
deterministically committing to any one
type of query you have a distribution
over these queries that you're asking
that's something that looks like
an online no stack of words type
question
another way to think about this is that
many of these algorithms
look at this as a function they think
about this function as just some
function of p
it's just that function is not very
nicely structured
and then what they have to do is to
design ways to get information about
this function
while sort of covering their basis in
terms of all possible ways that this
function could have been written
i'll talk very briefly when we come back
about bandits
i'm not going to go into the details of
them but that part hopefully is going to
answer your question a little bit more
but
because i didn't cover the computational
aspects yesterday i don't want to give
actual algorithms
right now
one more question
for finite games or
you can get this
the same thing i was telling you as long
as you
limit the possible size of others so you
serve it um different possible followers
right as long as you
make that small that said you can get
the same regret but usually logarithmic
in that size or something that has some
additional annoying dependencies on x
and y's again
it's a
yeah it's uh
actually it's very it's not that hard if
uh i just limit the types of games to
say that it's one of these k i just
don't know which one
i'm going to get like poly and k
and then root t and everything else but
to do better than poly k you need to use
structures of the game better
so let's take the rest of the line and
we'll have a third one drink
three or fifteen
seconds okay
sorry yes sorry you're right totally
right yes so this time it's gonna be a
15-minute break oh yes yes because we're
gonna have the town hall at 4 15 and
that's fine we need to exit the room
so we have some time for example we're
going to have a 15-minute break this
okay time see you guys at 3 15.
i finished on time you guys ask
questions we can start the town hall a
few minutes later it's fine yeah
yeah let's take a 20 minute break